>> Okay. So, let's
start. Welcome everyone.
Today, our speaker is Yu Cheng.
Yu Cheng did his PhD from
University of Southern California
advised by Xiang Guan Deng.
Now, he's a post-doc
at Duke University.
Yu Cheng's research
interest is in
intersection of
game theory and machine
learning and today he's
going to tell us about
non-convex Matrix
Completion, Yu Cheng.
>> Thanks for the introduction
and thanks for having me here.
I really appreciate you guys
showing up here rather than
attending the retirement
talk next door.
I'm going to try to wrap
up as quickly as I can,
so we don't miss
the party. So good.
This is a small audience,
so feel free to interrupt
and ask questions since
I'm treating this more as
a seminar thing even though
the talk that's recorded.
So, today, I'm going
to tell you about
non-convex matrix completion is
a joint work with Rong
from Duke University.
So in recent years,
non-convex optimization has
become quite successful in
practice like multi-layer
neural networks
becomes the dominating
approach to
many problems in computer vision
and speech recognition
and many other things.
However, the theoretical analysis
of non-convex optimization
still lags behind.
Recently, there has been a lot
of attention to try to improve
our understanding to
non-convex approaches
governed by this question.
Basically, can we explain
why they work very
well in practice?
Some of the question that
you can ask in this regime,
for example you could ask are
all the local optima
approximately global,
optimal for some given
objective function?
Can you understand
the structural geometry
of the objective function?
Can you use that to
design faster algorithms?
So, half of this talk belongs
to non-convex optimization.
The other half belongs to
spectral graph theory for
lack of a better name.
So, this is a field that bridge
together discrete and
continuous optimizations,
so if you look at
two separate fields,
one is like graph theory
which studies
discrete objects which has
combinatorial algorithms.
Studies graph trees paths flows.
The other, you have
numerical analysis towards where
people do iterative
algorithms look
at matrices and Eigenvectors.
Recently, there has been
quite a lot of
success in combining
these two fields to produce
faster algorithms
for luxury close,
say solving STD linear
systems max-flow,
better solver for
linear programming
and many, many other problems.
So, the other half of
this talk will belong to
spectral graph theory.
So, this is roughly where
this work comes in,
a high-level big picture.
So, now I'm going to dive into
the problem definition and
what I actually want to do
about matrix completion.
So, in the matrix
completion problem,
you have unknown n
by n matrix of rank
r. The input to
the problem is a subset
of entry reveal to you,
sometimes people assume as
uniformly at random independently
with some probability.
Your goal is look at
those entries and try
to recover this low-rank matrix.
Okay. This is a basic
machine learning problem
that has applications
to recommendation
systems and
collaborative filtering.
For example, you could think of
the rows of the matrix as
users and columns as movies.
If you observe entry,
it means in your system
a user rated movie,
gave some score to that movie.
The underlying low-rank
factorization just
means every movie has
some features and every user
has their preferences.
So, throughout this talk,
we're going to assume
the underlying matrix
is incoherent.
That is basically to avoid
this degenerate case
where it's only a very sparse
matrix, somewhere is one.
So, the assumption just says
all the singular values
should have similar norms,
and we're going to assume
all the observations
are noiseless.
So, no noise added,
just try to recover this matrix.
Okay? So traditionally,
the most classic approach to
this problem at least with
theoretical understanding
is convex relaxation.
So, you can formulate
this as minimizing
the nuclear norm of
the matrix subject
to that matrix agree with
all the observation you have.
Okay? So, nuclear norm is
just the sum of
the singular values of n. So,
what he actually wanted to
do is to minimize the rank
of the matrix subject
to this constraint but
this is simply hard.
So instead of minimizing
the L0 norm of
your singular values,
you just do L1 norm instead.
Okay? You can show that
if all the entries are
observed uniformly at random
and with sufficient probability,
then this convex program
will give you the exact solution,
will recover m. It can be solved,
it can be basically written as
SDP and solved in
time n to the four.
Okay. Not fast
enough in practice,
so we're not happy with that.
That's why in practice,
mostly people use a
non-convex heuristics.
The most intuitive non-convex
objective function
is just to solve for
a variable X that has
the same underlying dimension
than the low-rank factor
and you just want to minimize
the least squared error
where's the observations.
So, there has been a lot of
work on trying to understand why
a non-convex approaches works
very well for matrix
completion in practice.
So, in the beginning that
the earlier works focus on
what happens if I can
have careful initialization
mostly from SVD.
So basically, there
are a lot of work
show that if you start
at the right place then
run gradient descent,
you're going to end up
at the ground-truth.
The later, there are
more work giving a framework
based-approach for this
problem that showed
strong convexity near
the global optimum,
so that a lot of the algorithm
will actually work.
More recently, people
have been looking
at doing just gradient descent
without some special
initialization bases
start anywhere and
to show that this function
has no bad local optima.
I think Tony Mao was
here presenting some of
the work about two years ago,
a year half ago.
Right. So basically,
these are some of
the previous work on
convex and non-convex
matrix completion.
But the crucial thing
which motivated
our work is that all of
these papers on this slide,
these assume that all the entries
are revealed to you with
the same probability. Okay?
In this talk, we just want to ask
the following very
simple question.
That is, what if
they're not observed with
exactly the same probability.
They're just observed was
at least probability P. This
is more realistic
assumption in practice,
because let's say
a certain group of your users
might want to reveal
a certain subset of items
more often than the other people.
For example, man likes to
reveal- I don't know, something.
And the woman likes to
review shoes or something.
So, it's very surprising
to me at least why people
haven't been asking,
question this old assumption that
the probability are
exactly the same.
On the other hand, this is
actually very related
to another model,
where semi random adversary
can look at which samples
are revealed to you,
and then reveal
additional entry to you,
to try to introduce
a bad local optima in
your objective function.
Okay. So, the question we
want to answer here is,
are the previous
non-convex approaches
robust in their
semi-random model?
And if not, is there a way
that you can fix them?
But also still still
make them faster than
they're convex approaches.
So, from now on this talk
will be these three parts.
So, first, we're
going to show that
two counter examples to
the the previous
non-conscious approaches,
basically tell you that it's
possible that they can get
stuck in a bad local optima,
and even if you want to do
careful initialization with SVD,
It might give you a
totally wrong subspace.
Then, we're going to introduce
a pre-processing step,
that tries to reweight
the entries so that
the input becomes random.
Basically tried to undo what
the adversary did to the input.
Then, eventually I'm
going to prove to you
that after this
pre-processing step,
that the non-convex
objective function
has no bad local optima.
Okay. Good. So, now let me
first do the counter examples.
So, this is the recall the
non-convex objective function.
So, the counter example
just works like this.
I'm writing them as
the two-by-two matrices,
but they're actually
block matrices.
So, each one should be multiplied
by all ones matrix of size
of over two by over two.
P is the probability that
you observe this entry.
Okay. Basically, you're
much more likely to
observe entries from
these diagonal blocks,
than the off diagonal blocks.
X is the bad local optima that
I'm going to get stuck at,
which is roughly
equal to this number.
Okay. So, the way
we can verify that there is
a bad local optima near X,
is to basically say,
what's the expectation of
M* condition on
the revealed entries?
Okay. Because these entries
are revealed with
much higher probability,
this is what you
essentially get if you
take the expectation.
When all the entries are
observed with same probability,
this expectation is
exactly equal to M*.
But now it's different.
That's essentially the reason why
you can take this matrix,
and plug-in that expectation of
first order derivative
of f(x) is zero,
and the hash in the PSD.
That means if P is high enough,
then there will be
bad local optima near X.
Roughly speaking, the reason
why this is happening is
because the sampling is biased.
So that the actual thing
that your observed,
is biased because of P.
You becomes so local.
Sorry, this should be X.
So, X becomes a bad local optima
because it's eigen
vector of this matrix.
Is not rigorously true,
but that's roughly what's
going on here. Yes.
>> Why do we have
expectation of M*?
>> Because this is
the objective function
that you are using-
>> Yes.
>> Correct. Basically, you
can take the expectation of
f(x) and the probability
of ij in that's observed is given
by the big P matrix. That's why-
>> I guess the thing I
don't understand is,
the fact that this is
not bad local optima,
is high probability statement?
>> Yes. When P is high enough,
then- first of all,
if all the samples are
given uniformly at random,
when P is high enough, you
don't have that local optima.
>> I just don't get how
two by two example-
>> It is not two by
two. They're 2n by 2n,
and I'm just writing-
>> [inaudible] understand.
Can you expalin again?
>> Right. So, basically
all of these matrices
are n by n. But I'm writing out,
I'm partitioning them
into equal size blocks,
and I'm writing out the
number for that block.
You should take that
number and multiply
the all ones matrix
and fill it in there.
Okay. So, right.
That's roughly what's going on.
So, this is the first
counter-example that
shows when ij is not sampled
uniformly at random,
then this function could
potentially have
bad local optimum,
even when P is very large.
Another example we have in
the paper that I'm
going to omit here,
is we have a
four by four block matrix
that shows you if you
do SVD on the observed entries,
then that's not going to
give you the right subspace.
What I mean by that, is the angle
between the subspace
that you get from M.P,
again this is like the
expectation that you observe,
and the true subspace the angle
between these substances is
ninety degrees 90 degrees.
They're actually
orthogonal to each other.
So, these together are bad news.
Essentially says you have
no hope of doing
some careful initialization,
because you're going to go
totally wrong subspace.
If you start from a random point,
then you may end up in one
of these bad local optima,
as essentially induced by
the sampling probability matrix,
rather than the [inaudible].
Questions? Yes.
>> [inaudible]?
>> Okay, good. Good question.
So, the question is,
what about other approaches?
If I don't want to do gradient
descent on this function.
So, for example the first thing
first should say,
convex approaches still work.
The previous nuclear norm
minimisation program,
that still works.
Because given additional entry,
would not change the optimum
of that function.
So, that will still give
you the M-star back.
Jonathan was asking about SVD,
it depends. There are
some previous work on
deterministic conditions,
related to matrix completion
on deterministic conditions,
but they use connects
approaches as well.
But they didn't solve
the entire thing,
they used some other,
but it's in the paper.
For this talk, we're going to
specifically focus on just do
gradient descent on
this function, and ask,
can you do something
to the input,
so that you can avoid
the bad local optima?
Okay, good. So, now
let me tell you about
our preprocessing step.
Basically, we will look at
the first counter-example
and ask ourselves,
what went wrong?
So what happens is, if
all the entries are revealed
with the same probability,
this is roughly what you
expect to see from a matrix.
But in that counter-example,
the diagonal blocks are much
more likely to be observed
than the off diagonal blocks,
so you see something like this.
Let's say if the adversary
tells you that he's
changing the probability like
this, then what can you do?
Can you do something to
recover mSTAR, exactly?
One thing you can do is,
you can pretty much just
resample this diagonal block.
For example, you just
keep roughly 10 percent
of the elements here.
Then what you get
is essentially like
a uniform sample,
or more generally,
you can try to put
different weights
on the samples that you observe,
so that the weight that you get
from the diagonal and off
diagonal blocks are
roughly the same.
If you do this, essentially,
it's like your samples
are coming from
a uniform random distribution,
and then you'll be fine.
All right.
So, the key idea of
our preprocessing algorithm is
basically to re-weight
the sample,
so it looks like a random input,
and what do I mean by that?
First of all,
this is a weighted, non-commerce,
objective function.
So, if you take the graph
view of this matrix,
and then if I put an edge
between node I and node J,
if that entry is observed,
this matrix basically
corresponds like this graph.
So, it's an Erdos-Renyi graph
with probability p,
but then the versary added
some additional edge to
form these two very
dense sub-graphs.
Our algorithmic task here,
it's just to recover
a Erdos-Renyi random graph.
Basically, this is a graph
that's like expander
plus two clicks,
we just want to find
some expander from that graph.
That's exactly the problem we
solved in the preprocessing step.
Questions? All right.
So, the graph formulation
is following,
that you're given a graph G,
that you know contains
a subgraph that's similar
to some other graph H,
and you want to reweight G,
so that the weighted version
is spectrally similar
to H. For matrix completion,
H is just a complete graph
or an expander.
This problem, if you stare at it,
is very similar to a
well-established problem
in spectral graph theory,
that is Graph Sparsification.
So, Graph Sparsification is
a problem that gave
you a dense graph,
that you want to produce
some weighted sparse graph,
that have the same property,
say commute time,
and a lot of other things,
with the original graph.
It's been first proposed
by Spielman and Teng,
where they showed that if
you want two graphs
to be Epsilon close,
then you need to take an
over Epsilon squared edges,
this still their highest
polylog factors,
and M is number of edges,
N is the number of nodes.
Then, a beautiful work of Batson,
Spielman, and Srivastava,
they showed that you
can actually get away
with an over Epsilon
square edges this tight,
and the running time has then
been improved to
nearly linear time.
So, the algorithm we're using in
this paper for the preprocessing
is directly inspired by
the recent advancement
on this problem.
Now, I'm going to show you
the formal formulation
for these two problems.
Hopefully, you should be
convinced at their core,
they are essentially the same.
So, this is the spectral
sparsification problem.
I'm basically taking the vectors,
and then multiplying each
of them by L inverse half,
that's inverse half power
of the Laplacian,
so that the sum becomes identity.
So the spectral
sparsification problem is,
I give you a bunch of
rank one matrices,
whose sum is identity,
and I want you to find a set
of sparse coefficients,
so that their sum is
approximately identity.
The problem is
solved. The problem
we want to solve in this picture,
is to say that,
I give you a set of vector,
and I promise you, there
exists a subset of vectors.
That they sum up to
approximately 2i,
and now I asked you to
find a set of weights,
so that I don't have
the sparsity constraint,
but I don't know
this hidden subsets as well.
You can see that there are
some differences between
these two problems.
But, I'm going to explain to you
why some of the solution
for the first problem
can be applied
to our problem, and some cannot.
Hopefully, that will be
useful for you guys.
Good. Questions on
these two formulations?
>> Well, this is
a mainstay [inaudible]
>> Right. Yes.
>> How can I do this to
the previous work?
>> Good. The preprocessing part
is the main contribution
of this paper.
That's fair. Main technical
contribution of this paper?
>> [inaudible]
>> I will say
something at the end.
Before I work on this,
this is the part that I
couldn't see the most.
The rest are relatively
easier. I would say.
>> Did you just say
the problem two
is not the simple corollary
of problem one?
>> No.
>> You can't, or because
you cannot do rescaling?
>> For example, for this problem,
the very first approaches are
sampling by effective
resistance. Let's say.
>> Okay. You mean
the second part of that?
>> The first part,
sparsification.
>> Yes.
>> That is basically,
if the graph is,
let's say the graph
is nice enough,
is a complete graph, then
uniform sampling would work.
But in our problem,
there is an intuitive
argument why
any sampling algorithm
basically shouldn't work,
is because, you can't
check this premise,
in some sense. Well, I
mean you can check
by running this.
If you want to do sampling
by effective resistance,
it doesn't make sense, on
the second problem.
You can probably.
>> [inaudible]
>> Right.
>> Basically. Okay.
But, basically,
what happens in
the second problem,
is you have the underlying
graph, say your expander.
Then, I added some other
extra edges into this graph,
which causes spectrum to change.
For example, this graph
is not expander anymore,
it contains a expander.
But, it's mixing time in
these two clicks are much
faster than across the clicks.
In general, the underlying graph
I'm trying to recover
may not be expander. So.
>> Over time.
>> But, I can [inaudible].
>> You can still do something.
>> Do? Okay, we can
take this offline.
But, I hope I can
convince you at least
offline that problem two
is not a simple
correlative problem.
Okay. All right?
So, now, let me take
a slight detour to tell you
about how people handle
graph sparsification
problem and why
that routine is useful
for us. Okay? Yes.
>> So, you were running
them will be like N square?
>> Why?
I'll give you a nearly linear
time algorithm for
our problem two.
>> [inaudible].
>> Well. Okay. Good. For
matrix completion problem,
M doesn't have to be N square.
You only need to
observe roughly in
Log n and Log n entries.
>> So, using n.
>> But the adversary could
add a lot of interests to
your input and M would
be n squared maybe,
or if the probability is
higher than M is n squared.
Then, I can't do anything.
Maybe I can do anything
but in this paper,
we don't study that.
We just said that, if
you give me everything,
I'm going to read
it in first time.
>> Okay.
>> You can run
sparcification first.
So, you can always assume M
is roughly like a Log n or
Epsilon squared. Good. All right.
So, basically, the approach
in Batson, Spielman,
Srivastava, is they are going to
maintain the current sum of
these rank-one matrices.
They're going to start with
A equal to zero and two
barrier values that basically
sandwich this PSD matrix A.
So, initially, l would be minus,
minus something, or
minus a quarter or
something and u
would be a quarter.
So, basically, in
the very beginning,
it's a zero matrix
sandwich Pi minus i and i.
The algorithm will try to
add edge iteratively and
deterministically every time
to grow this ellipsoid,
while keeping it away from
the lower and upper barrier.
Okay? The important
thing for us here,
is the only thing you need to
know about this algorithm,
is they actually add edge
deterministically
in each iteration.
Why they are able to
show that it works?
Is they can say that a
good edge always exists,
because you can take
an average edge.
So, remember, in their problem
all the vector sum up to i.
Which means if you take
a tiny fraction of
an average edge.
So, basically, you
take a tiny fraction
of every edge then,
your ball, then, you're ellipsoid
would just grow by identity.
So you know that
one vector is going to
help you in the right potential
function that you define.
So, basically, you're going
to start with- basically,
the hope is the difference
between the two variables
are going to stay the same,
but the barriers would events
at roughly the same rate
and grow larger,
and larger, and this ellipsoid
will become more and
more like a sphere.
That's the idea behind the BSS.
Good. I want to talk about
this deterministically part.
So, basically, the algorithm can
directly be generalized
to handle our problem,
because the argument that
good edge exists hold
it for us as well.
In each situation, we know
a good edge exists as well.
Because if you look at
a subset of the edges,
the average on that
subset is good.
Even though we don't
know that's subset,
but we know a good edges
still exists.
So, you can basically just apply
BSS directly on our problem
and get away with it.
If I promise you the initial,
if I change this
condition to identity,
not approximately identity, then
you can just apply
BSS to our problem.
Then, you would solve this.
Good. So, the
conceptual contribution
of the preprocessing part
of our paper is basically,
BSS is actually more
powerful than just
applying it to graph
sparcification
is actually can be applied.
We believe it can be applied very
broadly to a lot of
semi-random settings.
The technical contribution
is basically two things.
One is that, like I said,
the total sum of your vector
is no longer identity.
So, for example, that
prevents you from
using some of the
sparcification techniques.
The other is, we need
to go in and basically
adapt the analysis so that it
works for this approximately
identity case.
So, one thing that we
need to do, for example,
is in BSS you can control
the upper and lower barrier
to move at roughly the same rate.
But now, you need to take into
consideration like how close
this is to identity, right?
Basically, you cannot hope
that these barriers would
events at the same rate,
because you're underlying
solutions not identity, right?
So, but, it's not very
hard to take care of
and you can do that.
That concludes this part
of the talk and before I
move to the next part,
let me tell you
the implication of
this preprocessing algorithm
to matrix completion.
So, basically,
the entire argument of the paper
goes roughly like this,
that if p is greater
than some value,
say Log n over n. Then,
you know that there exists
a set of good weights.
Why? You can just put weights
one on the entries
revealed by nature
and put weight zero on
the entries that later
added by the adversary.
Because a good set
of weights exist by
this problem that
we just proposed,
so you can find a set of weights
that's close to expander.
Then, oh, good.
So, the guarantee of
everything I've
presented just now is,
you can find this another
matrix W Tilde,
such that it's close to the all
ones matrix in spectrum
one and you can compute
it in nearly linear time.
Then, the rest of the talk,
I'm going to try to
give you a sketch of
why this condition is enough
to prove that the weighted
non-convex objective function
has no bad local optima.
Questions? Okay. All right.
So, now, we're moving to
the third part of the talk
which is to actually
do matrix completion.
So, again, let's recall this
weighted objective function,
let me rewrite it a little bit.
So, I'm going to rewrite it as
the inner product
of two matrices,
which is just basically,
you look at them as
if they are vectors,
but they're weighted by W. So,
these two are
the same thing, M star
is just the transpose.
So, the previous non-convex
matrix completion work
already tells us,
it's actually sufficient
that you just look at
the first and second order
condition for
this local optima in the
direction towards the optimum.
Basically, you're
just going to say,
"I'm at here and
the optimum is there,
and I'm only going to examine
everything that's happening on
that direction." That's fine.
That's enough to
introduce a contradiction
that axis, not a global optima.
So, this is just a calculation,
you're just going
to plug this in,
just treat plug in X plus Delta
here and take
all the first-order term
related to Delta, you get this.
If you take all the second term
Okay? If you stare
at these first and
second order condition,
you know the first-order
condition is zero because
derivative zero and you
know the second condition,
second order, the hashing in
this direction is at least zero.
A lot of these terms
are in common, so,
you can actually combine
them and cancel
them a little bit.
Recall that Delta is
equal to X minus Z.
So, let me use some shorthand.
Basically, A is
the first order approximation
of XX minus ZZ and B
is the actual matrix,
which has this annoying
second order term.
The first order condition
just says AB equal to
zero weighted by w.
The second order condition,
if you plug it in, it
roughly says this.
So, this slide is
my very poor attempt of
trying to convey to you how
non-convex matrix
completion works.
This is not the analysis in
the very beginning and it has
adapter several versions.
But now, I'm happy to say that
it can fit in two slides,
but you might need
to stare it for
some time to convince
yourself this actually
works like this.
So far, I haven't used
anything fancy, I just said,
"Look at the first
and second order condition
in the direction
of towards the optimum and
cancel a bunch of terms."
This is all we need to move on.
So, B is just this thing,
the XX minus M star,
thing we have.
So, this is
the condition we have.
Turns out from this,
if w is the [inaudible] matrix,
which means the
samples are uniform,
this is sufficient to show
that XX transpose
equal to M star,
at least you recover
M star exactly.
Why is that? Because you
can show that
the Frobenius norm of
Delta Delta square is the
most twice that much of this.
So, I'm not going to show
the proof of this lemma.
But what happens, is essentially,
you need to find
the right Z to align to.
So, basically, given an X,
you are going to
rotate Z a little
bit to minimize this Delta.
Then, you can try
to patch a bunch of things in
two squares and throw them away,
and whatever left is this term.
If you combine
these two conditions,
let's say W is [inaudible]
matrix, see old proof.
Then, that shows you M star
equal to XX transpose
because this first term
is going to knock
out two copies of this term here.
Then, you get minus M star
minus XX transpose is greater
than or equal to zero.
So, this thing in
the middle must be
there and that I believe
actually shows you,
if you do uniform sampling,
that's not true. I
want to say that
you don't need regularization,
but you actually do if
the p is not large enough.
But in this work,
all that we need to show is for
specific low rank
matrices like delta
and M star minus XX transpose,
the weighted norm under w is
similar to Frobenius Norm.
When you're taking samples
uniformly at random,
this just follows from
matrix concentration equality.
But now we need to replace
them with deterministic
condition.
That is the Spectral Norm between
w and j are ones matrix is small.
This is the lemma we
use in the paper.
Basically, like I said,
it relates the Norm
of a low-rank matrix
under weight W and
the Frobenius Norm to
the Spectral Norm stated
here and some other term
that's related
to the max rho norm of X and Y.
Okay? This also justifies
why you need to do
regularization.
Because one of
these term come from
the incoherence and the other one
is your matrix and
you need to basically
take good care of it,
so make sure it doesn't blow up.
But anyway, I'm not
going to dive into
the detail of this,
but essentially this is
the most crucial thing
that you need to change
in the analysis.
You need to replace
the matrix concentration balance
with this Spectral
Norm condition.
Okay. Finally, we get
that after the
pre-processing algorithm,
any local optima of fx actually
satisfy this condition.
It can recover the,
that doesn't make sense,
it should be this.
So, my residual,
the Frobenius Norm
squared of my residue
is at most epsilon of
the original thing.
I proved this but, yes,
okay, good. Questions?
>> As the lemma.
So, why do we get, again,
the w minus j is small?
>> Because nature revealed
enough sample to you.
If you only look
at the sample from
nature it gives you expander.
The pre-processing
algorithm recover
expander from expander
plus garbage.
>> First j's are just
trying to lessen.
>> J is not.
>> There is expander for W.
>> No. W does
your rescale for you.
So, W is any non-negative weights
you can put on the samples.
>> Jp times W.
>> Now, W is like
one over P time.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes, you're right.
You need to put it somewhere.
We'll put it in W.
Yes, I'm happy to tell
you more about this.
Okay. Now, I'm just
going to conclude.
So, basically our main results
are are threefold.
First is we pose and study
non-convex matrix completion
and basic question
this commonly used assumption
that Pij equal to p and we'll
say is at least p. What happens?
We shall counter examples that
the existing non-convex
approach would not work.
Then in light of
this negative results,
we propose a
preprocessing problem
and we showed that you can solve
this in nearly linear time
and get some good
spectral property
from your weight matrix.
Then using that property,
you can show that
the non-convex objective
has no bad local optima.
So, you can just run
gradient descent or
alternative minimization on
it and you will be fine.
Good. So, the other main
conceptual contribution
of this work is basically
we're trying to bridge
together to relatively
young field.
One is Spectral graph
theory that develops
fast algorithms based
on the connection
between discrete and
continuous optimization,
and the other is
a theoretical analysis
of non-convex algorithms.
Basically, in this work
we showed that you
can get efficient algorithm
by mostly using non-commercial
approach but run
a very lightweight convex
optimization in the beginning.
You sort of, like get
better outcomes both.
Good. Okay. Open problems,
so are two of them.
One is that actually,
this should be exact recovery.
There's something that I'm
sweeping under the rug here.
Previous results were able to
show that if P is large enough,
you can actually
exactly recover M star.
But in our people who
actually we can show that,
and I have a counter example
of that actually being false.
So, you cannot
recover it exactly,
you can only recover it up to
some epsilon Frobenius Norm.
Behind that is really
this question is,
how much samples do the adversary
needs to reveal to
you so that you can
actually get stuck in
local minima that's
close to the global optimum?
We don't know the answer
to this question.
What we're really
hoping to say is that
the adversary must reveal
say- what I really want
to say is 50 percent of
the samples needs to
come from the adversary.
For the adversary
to mess you up..
Okay if if only one percent is
coming from the adversary,
then you are still fine.
I really want to
prove that statement,
but I couldn't so
there's an open problem.
Then I think
the more important one
is the conceptual one.
That is, can you apply
the Basil Spellman Srivastva
framework or packing
SDP solvers in general to
more semi-random problems.
I know the question is yes.
I know one other problem
that you can apply this to.
I'm pretty sure there
are plenty more,
I mean, it's just
packing SDP solvers.
So, now you can solve
them fast enough.
Can do magic with them in
practice and that's it.
>> Can you give anything
if you just get
a p fraction of
your matrix but it's
a random entries if you
[inaudible] fraction.
>> Well, for example
if I never observe
entries from one row or
column then there's
no hope I can recover.
Right? Even if its rank one. So-
>> Maybe a p fraction from [inaudible]
something. Because [inaudible]
>> You need to be,
right. So, good.
No. Because for example,
you could have,
if you only observe entries
from the diagonal blocks
then you can't do it.
The way I think about it is like
think of the rank one case.
What you can really
do is if you observe
these three entries and you can
construct this triangle within.
If you have two edges then you
can recover the third edge.
So, what you're really
saying is your graph
needs to be connected
in some sense.
But every node has
degree at least
Pn doesn't guarantee the graph
to be connected, right?
>> Right?
>> So, you need to
be careful about
what conditions you put on this.
All right thanks very much.